we are in the call a phone bank as
Medicare open enrollment is underway and
that poses a lot of or has a lot of
people posing questions about what plan
is right for them well you can get
answers to your questions until seven
o'clock tonight by calling the number on
your screen
702-650-1101 as Medicare open enrollment
continues also to answer questions for
us today we have with us Dr Mark
ferdocian of sunset clinics part of the
Optum Care Network of Nevada thanks for
being here first of all thank you for
having me why is this open enrollment
period so important well open enrollment
is a critical time for seniors because
it's their opportunity to either enroll
or make changes to their Medicare or
Medicare Advantage plans and choose a
primary doctor from one of the local
providers like me right because there
are different benefits in all of the
different plans what are some of those
that's right Optum has their own
Pharmacy so you can get a hundred day
supply there is a mobile medical centers
that you can see and be seen at and they
also additionally allow for patients to
be seen at home to have their physicals
Sunset clinics as I understand it has
multiple locations what are some of the
services you provide so all good health
care starts with a good annual Well
Visit and that annual well visit then
will tailor a specific health care plan
for the patient
meantime it can be difficult to pick the
right plan and complicate it what are
some resources that you would Point
people toward to help them make that
decision
that's correct the health plans change
yearly so it's very important that you
understand the plan you're looking at
Additionally
the budget needs to fit where your cost
and overhead needs to be looked at and
additionally
patients should consider the doctors
that they are seeing and make sure that
the health plan covers not only the
doctors but the prescriptions that
they're currently taking well Dr Mark
verdosing of sunset clinics thanks so
much for being here really appreciate
your help another great resource is
right here until seven o'clock tonight
when you have questions about your
Medicare Plan what's right for you are
the Specialists covered is your doctor
covered your prescriptions all those
questions do have answers and these
people can put you on the right track
702-650-1101 is the number to call and
again they'll be here until seven
o'clock tonight back to you
[Music]